in our last video we talked about why
call might lose in the battle against
godzilla in the upcoming movie
if you haven't seen it then you can
check it out after this one
it will also be displayed in the end
screens in this one right now we will go
in depth
on both the battle axe that kong was
seen using in the trailer
and also we will see how mechagodzilla
might have been created
this is one of many many breakdowns of
the trailer that we have
made that was shown to us in this month
but we hope that there won't be any
second trailer as everything might
be dissected and the movie would be seen
before it is seen if you
get what i mean so let us see how both
of these are made
their origins if you may let's do it
the battle axe in the trailer okay so
let's start with the battle axe
the super weapon that kong will be using
against godzilla in the movie
in a trailer comb was first seen holding
and dragging something
which we expect might be the axe in the
scene where he meets the little girl gia
and then we can see it more clearly when
he was raising it above his head
sounding a battle cry while a couple of
alien looking hollow earth anti-gravity
vehicles are hovering in the background
then we see a close-up of it when he was
about to face godzilla in daylight scene
then again when he was running and
charging against the g-man
which continued with the scene of
godzilla shooting his atomic breath
but sadly the axe absorbed it and it was
used to hack his face
ending in an explosion so what is it
made of
when we first saw glimpses of the battle
axe last year in the toy leaked images
it was very clear that it was a dorsal
plate of godzilla or maybe from one of
godzilla's species
that was used as the blade of the weapon
that was confirmed when we first saw the
trailer
it would make sense as only a weapon
made from godzilla himself can penetrate
his tough height
the axe glows blue not unlike bilbo's
letter opener sting
which is more curious is the handle of
the axe it was first thought to be made
of some kind of wood but then
that is too fragile in a battle of the
titans then we see it
was a bone a thigh bone from another
titan most probably
but which one the most probable
candidate for this is demuto since the
lack of the murder can emit emp
and while doing that it glows red in
color much like the handle of the axe
which makes sense as the emp could dial
down the intensity of the atomic breath
so who made it and where was it made
theories around this are vast and one
can only choose one or the other
but by looking at the trailer kong was
seen battling the warbats without the
weapon
which means he was on the road to
retrieving it inside the hollow earth
this could have happened before kong was
transported away on the ship
but then again we did not see any
evidence of the weapon during that time
so kong would have gotten the axe when
he travels to the hollow earth
after that battle but it is yet to be
confirmed so
some say that kong made the axe from
godzilla's dorsal plates
but time doesn't allow him to do that
and survive
so the best theory is that it was made
by gong's ancestors and the hollow earth
and i was left there after an unknown
cataclysm that led them away from the
place to skull island
and that kong had to go back there to
get it
but how is it effective in a fight
against godzilla
well like i said earlier the axe is made
up of two things that are already deadly
against the giant lizard one which has
evolved to be a part of him
his dorsal plate which actually is
impermeable
and immune to the atomic breath in fact
it has the ability to absorb
and store the energy kind of like a
capacitor or a battery
and no wonder kong could use it to
deflect and absorb the godzilla
kamehameha
another thing is that the bone which is
most probably the muted thigh bone
just a theory again mind you the muted
bone can still emit emp while being
powered by the dorsal plates lingering
energy
and this emp can lessen and dial down
the power of the atomic breath
we can clearly see that godzilla's
2014's breath
was weak against the murals as they have
evolved this defense mechanism
specifically to counter godzilla so
that's that
now let's see the other elephant in the
room mecca godzilla
in the first scene of the trailer we see
an explosion that happened in a city
that is in asia
soil in south korea or maybe hong kong
and there was no thailand or monster
anywhere to be seen
there were a series of explosions in
fact and they don't seem to have that
lingering fire that is usually seen in
explosives
which only means that this was from a
strange energy source
and that would be seen in the movie then
we get to the scene where people are
fleeing and running underground hiding
from something
why do people do that hide underground
in metro stations
when titans or kaiju's fight anyway
it is here that we get our first look
into mecca godzilla
it was a short second of him but it is
unmistakable
the mechanized titan that humans are
creating as was seen in the end credit
scenes of kotm
it was silver and had red glowing
parts which might be his power systems
around one minute and 42 seconds into
the trailer we see
ren serizawa standing in front of a
screen that showed specs and statistics
of mecha godzilla
he would be the estranged son of
sarizawa that seeks revenge
on godzilla because of the death of his
father
in the screen we can see written on it
the battery systems
and also the minimum charge which means
that mechagodzilla has to be charged in
order to fight
mechagodzilla will have a very segmented
body with various modular parts
and the most visible feature are the
four-toed feet
we can also see acoustic signatures down
in the screen meaning that it will be
able to sound out alpha calls
or also its bio signatures if needed so
there are many
mecha godzilla theories running a mock
in the internet and the comments
sections of various youtube videos
including our own and the most common
one is that mechagodzilla would be like
his first incarnation where he can
camouflage himself to look like godzilla
and therefore destroying cities and
everything in sight to turn the world
against the g-man
to frame him but that too might be false
it might just be the g-man hunting maker
godzilla
so going back to the topic at hand how
is mechagodzilla made
first of all we can see him being all
silver and shiny like a freaking
tablespoon
so yes he will be made of metal and if
we look at how he can walk through
buildings demolishing them like paper
houses
it means that the outer layer will be
made of some tough
and super durable alloy of course it
will be like vibranium or mandalorian
steel
in that it is fictional but even that
would need a body frame
to stand out like the g-man so i'm
guessing monarch or
apex would use the skeleton of dagon as
a template
for the creation of this mechanized
titan for those who
don't know who dagon is he is an
ancestor of godzilla that died
fighting muto prime and his remains were
seen in the beginning of
godzilla 2014 so the body is complete
but what about the brain and the head
well king of the monsters gave
us that the decapitated head of ghidorah
would be used to steer and
function this mecca and create the brain
waves and biosignature
it isn't really a new thing in fact
ghidorah has been used in the past
touhou movies to construct mechagodzilla
but everything went haywire when he
regains consciousness and takes over
control systems of the mecca
which might actually happen again with
this one too so here we have it
this is just again a theory no leaked
plots or images
just utilizing this kaiju fan brain to
connect the dots
so mechagodzilla would be made up of
ghidorah's goofy head kevin
dagon's skeletal system and a very hot
alloy exterior
the bellaghs would be made up of
godzilla or
godzilla species dorsal blade a muted
thigh bone
tied pretty tight with the skin of a
warbat i hope
would be great seeing kong you know
skinning a warbat
that seems about right anyway put your
thoughts down there
in the comments section on this matter
and like subscribe for more videos
and also smash that notification bell
for regular updates
till the next one take care